[Music]
wandering the streets I was looking for
a taxi but to go where and one in my
uterus yeah
ignite nuclear fusion and what's yours
baby
this is my shirt it's actually the Orion
Nebula yeah
taken by the Hubble Space Telescope nice
that would be a good name
orion hubble space it's a girl do I tell
the Hopi yeah oh it's a boy I'll tell
everybody I'm usually kind of cagey
about it well you have to tell us at
some point who cares if it's now or in
two weeks it's the baby's sex and not
the baby's gender the baby gets to
decide their gender okay tenderize fluid
no I haven't come to terms with people
asking about this are you gonna pick a
general with the fetus that's in my I
think no names are really genderless but
maybe gender-neutral I don't know what
who's not wearing their seat belts that
came out Cameras Cameras or not we gotta
put on your seat belt
put on your buckle here we go strapping
you a strapping in okay
enforcement it's not irony yeah yeah so
Emily your your research is yeah it's
star formation isn't it a little bit
yeah it's kind of related I study brown
dwarfs mm-hmm which are kind of the
lowest mass products of star formation
some of those will be born in a star
forming yeah yeah so there's there's
brown dwarfs in the Orion Nebula they're
a little bit too far away for us to see
in detail but there's a lot of brown
dwarfs that are closer to us so we can
see and one of the things that we don't
necessarily understand about brown
dwarfs is how they exactly form and how
they evolved throughout their lifetimes
the things that we want to study yeah
very nice I study both young and old
between planets and stars yeah you can
think about them as kind of in-between
objects like they don't well they kind
of do because they they form like stars
do out of a collapsing cloud of gas and
dust but then they kind of they don't
have enough mass to start nuclear fusion
and shine the way a star does so and so
these objects kind of cool and fade with
time and end up resembling gas giant
planets so wait a minute if I'm getting
this correctly a brown dwarf is very
much like my career the good thing about
a brown dwarf you're fading is that it
lives forever it's because it's not a
star and we call it we consider a star's
lifetime like the lifetime the time for
which it fuses hydrogen and helium which
is temporary for most stars I mean
that's not a time coming since it never
ignited nuclear fusion
it was never alive to begin with to then
later on die
yeah maybe but it was luminous still and
never ignited nuclear fusion but it had
energy from its original gravitational
collapse and so it still shines the very
shine in the infrared you know
we could consider them indie stars oh no
they never quitted but they still made
it in there alright yeah red light you
can see them at the you know the indie
theater at midnight on a Tuesday night